- Vítej zpět u kurzu Porozumění kvantovým informacím a výpočtům.
Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro
vzdělávání v IBM Quantum.
Toto je sedmá lekce série a v této lekci probereme problém odhadu fáze a to, jak ho můžeme vyřešit
na kvantovém počítači.
Poté aplikujeme odhad fáze na problém faktorizace celých čísel, který jsme probrali v předchozí lekci.
Získáme tak Shorův algoritmus, který umožňuje faktorizovat celá čísla s polynomiálními náklady nebo v polynomiálním čase, pokud chceme
uvažovat z hlediska potřebného času spíše než z hlediska počtu
elementárních operací.
Toto je v jistém smyslu klenot
kvantových algoritmů, a přestože faktorizace velkých celých čísel
může mít pro většinu lidí omezené využití, zůstává jedním z nejpřesvědčivějších důkazů, které máme pro hypotézu, že kvantové počítače nabídnou výrazné výhody
oproti klasickým počítačům. Zde je přehled lekce.
Začneme definicí samotného problému odhadu fáze a poté probereme metodu řešení tohoto problému
na kvantovém počítači.
Budeme postupovat krok za krokem, počínaje tím, co si můžeš
představit jako jakési zahřívací cvičení.
V problému odhadu fáze je cílem přiblížit
určité reálné číslo a v této části zahřívacího cvičení uvidíme, jak můžeme získat
velmi nepřesnou
aproximaci tohoto čísla.
To nebude
dostatečně dobré pro faktorizaci, když aplikujeme naše řešení
problému odhadu fáze na faktorizaci celých čísel,
ve skutečnosti budeme potřebovat poměrně přesnou aproximaci, ale přesto je užitečné začít s tímto zahřívacím cvičením,
abychom si udělali představu o tom,
jak celá věc funguje.
Poté probereme otázku, jak získat větší přesnost, a to přirozeně povede
k operaci známé jako kvantová Fourierova transformace.
Uvidíme, co přesně tato operace je a jak ji lze implementovat
pomocí kvantového circuit.
A jakmile ji budeme mít, budeme ji moci aplikovat
na odhad fáze a dojdeme k obecnému postupu pro řešení problému
s velmi vysokou přesností.
Poté v poslední části lekce uvidíme, jak nám řešení problému
odhadu fáze umožní efektivně faktorizovat celá čísla.
A konkrétně dostaneme Shorův algoritmus pro
faktorizaci celých čísel, nebo alespoň něco, co je ekvivalentní Shorovu algoritmu.
Funguje to tak, že si v podstatě dáme odrazový můstek, což je ještě další problém nazývaný problém hledání řádu.
Konkrétně uvidíme, jak můžeme vyřešit problém hledání řádu pomocí postupu odhadu fáze, a poté uvidíme, jak můžeme faktorizovat celá čísla
řešením problému hledání řádu. Začneme speciálním případem věty nazvané spektrální věta,
a konkrétně se zaměříme na to, co nám tato věta říká
pro unitární matice.
Spektrální věta je
velmi důležitá věta z lineární algebry a
funkcionální analýzy.
Říká nám něco zajímavého o tom, jak lze určitá lineární zobrazení vyjádřit v určité formě, která se často nazývá
spektrální rozklad,
což je z mnoha důvodů užitečné.
A jak jsem řekl, zaměříme se na to, co tato věta říká
pro unitární matice.
Spektrální věta je
obecnější než to. Nefunguje pro všechny matice, ale funguje pro třídu matic
zvaných normální matice, které zahrnují všechny unitární matice i některé matice,
které unitární nejsou.
Ale jen pro zjednodušení omezíme naši pozornost
na unitární matice, protože to je vše, co pro
účely této lekce potřebujeme.
Zde je znění spektrální věty pouze pro unitární matice.
Předpokládejme, že U je
unitární matice N krát N.
Věta říká,
že musí existovat ortonormální báze
vektorů psi jedna až psi N,
spolu s N komplexními čísly
Lambda jedna až Lambda N, všechna ležící na komplexní jednotkové kružnici, takže U lze vyjádřit
tak, jak je zapsáno v této rovnici.
Toto se nazývá spektrální
rozklad U, jak jsem již zmínil, a může být velmi výhodné vědět, že U lze tímto způsobem zapsat.
Někdy může být výhodné mít tyto vektory a tato čísla, když pracujeme s
konkrétní unitární maticí U, a může být také velmi
užitečné prostě vědět,
že takový výraz je vždy možný, jako způsob dokazování určitých vlastností unitárních matic například.
V tomto znění věty je každé z těchto čísel,
Lambda jedna až lambda N, zapsáno konkrétním způsobem
jako E na mocninu dva pí I krát theta, kde každé z theta
theta jedna až theta N je reálné číslo, a
k tomuto způsobu
zápisu každého z těchto
čísel se ještě vrátíme.
Důležitá věc, které si všimneš
ohledně těchto vektorů a čísel, je, že každý vektor psi
K musí být vlastní vektor matice U s
odpovídající vlastní hodnotou lambda K.
To znamená, že pokud
vynásobíme psi K maticí U, dostaneme lambda K krát psi K.
Takže U s každým z těchto vektorů jednoduše násobí odpovídající číslo lambda K.
Pro obecný libovolný vektor takto U fungovat nebude, ale vlastní vektory jsou speciální.
A věta nám říká, že ve skutečnosti existuje
ortonormální báze těchto vlastních vektorů.
Tato rovnice dole mimochodem plyne z výrazu, který máme pro U z věty, spolu se skutečností, že
vektory jsou ortonormální.
WEBVTT
Pokud vynásobíš
výraz U jakýmkoli psi K a použiješ ortonormalitu vektorů, dostaneš součet, ve kterém
jsou všechny členy nulové
kromě jednoho, a tento jeden člen, se kterým zůstaneme, vypadá takto.
Nyní můžeme definovat
problém odhadu fáze.
Tento problém je trochu
neobvyklý, jak uvidíme.
Dostaneme dvě věci. Za prvé dostaneme popis unitárního kvantového circuit,
který působí na N qubitech
pro nějakou volbu N, a když říkáme, že se jedná o unitární circuit,
myslíme tím pouze to, že všechny
gates jsou unitární, takže v tomto circuit
nejsou žádná měření.
Za druhé dostaneme N-qubitový stav psi, a to je ta neobvyklá část.
Ve skutečnosti máme vstup
kvantového stavu pro tento problém, a to jednu kopii tohoto stavu.
U všech ostatních výpočetních problémů, o kterých jsme v této sérii mluvili, byl vstup klasický, buď ve formě řetězce
bitů nebo jako černá skříňka.
A to není překvapivé, protože výpočetní
problémy, se kterými se setkáváme v každodenním životě, bývají klasické,
protože to jsou
problémy, na kterých nám nejvíce záleží.
Tento problém si můžeš
představit tak, že se jedná o něco, co se vyskytuje nebo pravděpodobně bude vyskytovat jako dílčí problém.
A postup odhadu fáze, se kterým nakonec přijdeme, je něco, co
obecně používáme jako podprogram
uvnitř nějakého většího výpočtu, pravděpodobně pro klasický
problém, na kterém nám záleží.
Toto bude slibný problém a stav psi není
jen libovolný kvantový stav.
Je slíbeno, že psi je vlastní vektor libovolné unitární operace U, kterou popisuje daný circuit.
A cílem je najít nebo
aproximovat vlastní hodnotu, která odpovídá vlastnímu vektoru psi.
Formulujme problém
trochu přesněji.
Vstup se skládá z unitárního
kvantového circuit na N qubitech, který lze zakódovat jako řetězec bitů
libovolnou metodou, kterou upřednostňujeme pro kódování popisů kvantových circuit, spolu s N-qubitovým stavem psi.
Circuit můžeme nazvat jakkoli chceme, ale co skutečně záleží z hlediska formulace tohoto problému, je samotná unitární operace
prováděná při spuštění circuit, a tuto unitární operaci
popisuje matice U.
Ale U nám není dáno jako matice, dostaneme pouze popis kvantového circuit, který U implementuje.
Slib, jak jsem již uvedl, je, že psi je vlastní vektor U.
Takže pokud bychom spustili náš circuit na psi, dostali bychom psi vycházející vynásobené vlastní hodnotou,
což by v té situaci bylo
globální fází.
A nakonec výstupem problému je aproximace vlastní hodnoty odpovídající psi, a konkrétně hledáme
aproximaci reálného čísla theta, mezi nulou a jednou, zahrnující
nulu, ale ne jednu,
která splňuje rovnici,
kterou máme na obrazovce.
Abychom vysvětlili tento způsob
parametrizace vlastní hodnoty odpovídající psi a také objasnili, co myslíme aproximací,
nakresleme obrázek
komplexní jednotkové kružnice.
Můžeme umístit čísla jedna, I,
mínus jedna a mínus I na jejich obvyklá místa a zvážit
libovolný bod na
kružnici parametrizovaný pomocí theta, jak je uvedeno ve formulaci problému.
To je bod, který
dostaneme, pokud začneme od jedné a otočíme o úhel
dvě krát pí krát theta, takže úhel není
theta, ale dvě pí theta,
a jiný způsob, jak o tom přemýšlet, je, že pokud začneme od jedné a urazíme vzdálenost dvě pí theta na samotné kružnici,
dostaneme se do našeho bodu, E na
dvě krát pí krát theta.
Každý bod na komplexní jednotkové kružnici lze takto vyjádřit
pro jedinečnou volbu theta.
A to proto, že projdeme
celou kružnici, jak theta přechází od nuly k jedné, a kdybychom šli celou
cestu k theta rovnající se jedné,
vrátili bychom se tam,
kde jsme začali při theta rovnající se nule, proto zahrnujeme nulu, ale nezahrnujeme jednu.
Jen abychom se ujistili, že každý
bod na komplexní jednotkové kružnici odpovídá jedinečné hodnotě theta v rozsahu, který zvažujeme.
Existují různé způsoby,
jak si lze představit aproximaci konkrétní hodnoty theta, ale způsob, jakým to budeme dělat, je aproximace theta zlomkem,
kde jmenovatel
je dvě na mocninu M pro nějakou volbu kladného celého čísla M a čitatel je celé číslo y
mezi nulou a dvě na M mínus jedna.
Můžeš si to představit jako M-bitovou aproximaci theta, pokud chceš, a toto
číslo bychom mohli zapsat v binárním zápisu,
kde máme binární tečku následovanou binárním
vyjádřením Y.
Říkám binární tečka mimochodem
spíše než desetinná tečka, protože desetinný znamená základ 10 a já mluvím o základu dvě,
ale jde o stejnou myšlenku.
Ale v každém případě si to můžeme
také jednoduše představit jako zlomek, jak
se zobrazuje na obrazovce.
A pro jasnost, když přemýšlíme o
aproximacích v tomto kontextu, je třeba chápat,
že hodnoty theta
WEBVTT
blízké nule a hodnoty theta blízké jedné jsou ve skutečnosti blízko sebe.
Například, pokud theta je rovno 0,99 a my aproximujeme tuto hodnotu
theta hodnotou nula,
pak je to poměrně dobrá aproximace v tom smyslu, že se liší pouze o jednu setinu od skutečné hodnoty, když
obejdeme kružnici
a vrátíme se na nulu, když dosáhneme jedničky.
Termín modulo jedna se někdy používá k popisu situace, kdy v podstatě
ztotožňujeme theta rovná se jedna s theta rovná se nula.
Jde o to, že nám skutečně záleží na poloze bodu
E na dvě pí I theta na jednotkové kružnici,
a přemýšlení o tomto
způsobu aproximace theta dává smysl, pokud máme tento cíl na mysli.
Samotná formulace problému,
jak se zobrazuje na obrazovce, nespecifikuje, jak dobrá musí aproximace theta být,
ale to je něco, co můžeme doladit podle našich potřeb.
V některých situacích nám může vyhovovat aproximace theta s nízkou přesností a v jiných situacích budeme požadovat
velmi přesnou aproximaci a formulace problému
může být odpovídajícím způsobem upřesněna.
Dále uvidíme, jak můžeme vyřešit
problém odhadu fáze na kvantovém počítači, a
začneme zahřívacím cvičením.
Toto nebude naše konečné
řešení problému.
Využijeme fenomén phase kickback k tomu, abychom se pokusili zjistit něco
o vlastní hodnotě odpovídající danému vlastnímu vektoru.
Připomeňme, že v problému
odhadu fáze nám je dán popis
unitárního kvantového circuit pro nějakou operaci U,
a to, co nejprve uděláme, je použití tohoto popisu circuit k vytvoření nového circuit, který implementuje řízenou operaci U, jak je
zobrazeno na obrazovce.
To je poměrně jednoduché. Můžeme přidat řídicí qubit, který je zobrazený
nahoře v tomto diagramu,
a použít tento nový řídicí
qubit jako řízení pro každý jednotlivý gate, který
se vyskytuje v našem circuit.
Takže všechny gates se aplikují, pokud je tento řídicí qubit nastaven na jednu, a žádný z nich se neaplikuje, pokud je řídicí qubit nastaven na nulu,
to znamená, že budeme
potřebovat řízenou verzi každého gate, který
se vyskytuje v circuit U, ale nemusíme přemýšlet o těchto nových řízených gates
jako o jednotlivých gates, pokud nechceme. Mohly by být implementovány
jako malé circuits sestavené z gates z libovolné sady gates,
kterou jsme se rozhodli použít. A jakmile máme řízenou verzi U, můžeme zvážit spuštění tohoto circuit,
kde nejprve uvedeme řídicí qubit do superpozice nuly a jedničky, aplikujeme řízený gate U na vlastní vektor, který nám byl dán,
a poté aplikujeme Hadamard gate
na řízení a provedeme měření.
Uvidíme, proč má smysl to dělat, až projdeme analýzou, ale ještě než se dostaneme k detailům, okamžitě vidíme podobnost
například s Deutschovým algoritmem, kde aplikujeme
několik Hadamard gates a měříme jako způsob
efektivního zkoumání
toho, co daná
operace tady dělá.
Je to řízený unitární operátor
spíše než dotazovací gate, ale hrají tu roli velmi podobné myšlenky.
Podívejme se tedy, co circuit dělá.
Počáteční stav je vlastní vektor psi, tensorovaný se stavem nula
pro řídicí qubit,
aplikace prvního Hadamard gate transformuje stav
horního qubit na stav plus a celý
stav můžeme rozepsat, jak je ukázáno právě zde.
Poté aplikujeme řízenou operaci U a ta aplikuje U na psi, když je řídicí qubit nastaven na jedničku,
ale ne když je nastaven na nulu. Takže dostaneme stav pí dvě,
který je zapsán na obrazovce.
Stav můžeme zjednodušit
pomocí skutečnosti, že psi je vlastní vektor U s vlastní hodnotou e na dvě pí I theta.
Takže dostaneme tuto vlastní hodnotu násobící druhý
člen, ale ne první.
A můžeme zjednodušit pomocí bilinearity
tenzorového součinu.
Takže to, co máme, je fenomén phase kickback, ale tentokrát se to děje pro libovolný vlastní vektor psi libovolné unitární operace U,
na rozdíl od aplikace operace NOT na stav mínus konkrétněji.
To je tedy stav po aplikaci řízené operace U.
Mimochodem, stojí za to
vzít si chvíli a všimnout, že stav dolních N qubitů je stále vlastní vektor psi.
Což je skvělé, protože nám to
dává příležitost použít ho znovu, pokud se tak rozhodneme.
Poté je proveden druhý Hadamard gate a zde je stav, který dostaneme.
Neukázal jsem zde všechny
podrobnosti odvození, ale pokud aplikuješ
Hadamard gate a zjednodušíš, toto bys měl dostat.
To je tedy stav těsně
před měřením.
Zaměříme se na tento stav, abychom viděli, co můžeme zjistit
o theta měřením.
A pokud změříme horní
qubit nebo nejpravější qubit, toto jsou pravděpodobnosti, které dostaneme pro dva výsledky.
A zde jsem použil
několik základních vzorců, které spojují siny a kosiny
s komplexními exponenciálami, abychom vyjádřili tyto pravděpodobnosti
pomocí sinů a kosinů.
Konkrétně pravděpodobnost dostát nulu je kosinus na druhou pí krát theta a pravděpodobnost dostát jedničku
WEBVTT
je sinus na druhou stejného úhlu. A to dává smysl,
protože sinus na druhou plus kosinus na druhou
libovolného úhlu je rovno jedné.
Takže naše pravděpodobnosti
se sčítají na jedničku, jak očekáváme.
A zde je graf těchto pravděpodobností jako funkce theta.
Pro jasnost, jedná se o graf
samotných pravděpodobností, na rozdíl od grafu znázorňujícího například jediné rozdělení pravděpodobnosti.
Například, pokud theta
je rovno jedné polovině, pak pravděpodobnost, že
dostaneme výsledek jedna, který je nakreslen fialově, je rovna jedné,
zatímco pravděpodobnost
dostat výsledek nula, který je nakreslen modře, je nula.
Na druhou stranu, pokud theta je rovno jedné
čtvrtině nebo třem čtvrtinám, pak každý ze dvou výsledků je stejně pravděpodobný.
A samozřejmě pro všechny volby theta je součet pravděpodobností roven jedné, jak jsme již pozorovali.
Takže z tohoto postupu přesně nezjistíme, jaké theta je, ale dává nám to určité
informace o theta.
A pokud si představíme situaci, kdy je slíbeno,
že theta je rovno nule nebo theta je rovno jedné polovině, tento postup nám řekne,
která z těchto dvou
možností platí.
To je tedy jednoduchý způsob, jakým můžeme použít fenomén phase kickback k zjištění něčeho o vlastní hodnotě.
Jak tedy můžeme zjistit více
o vlastní hodnotě?
No, toto je situace, kdy nás může
nevědomost vést.
Protože skutečně není
příliš mnoho věcí, které můžeme dělat.
Nevíme téměř nic
o vlastním vektoru sin a také moc nevíme
o operaci U.
Máme circuit pro U, ale pro naše účely to může být
hrozný, matoucí chaos, ze kterého nedokážeme
nic vyčíst jeho prohlídkou.
Ale jedna přirozená možnost je spustit circuit vícekrát.
Konkrétně bychom mohli zkusit udělat přesně to, co jsme právě udělali, s tím rozdílem, že místo aplikace jediné řízené operace U,
tuto operaci aplikujeme dvakrát. Nebo ji můžeme aplikovat libovolný počet krát, ale začněme dvakrát,
jen abychom viděli, co se stane.
No, co se stane, je vlastně poměrně
jednoduché. Dvojnásobnou aplikací řízené
operace U v podstatě pouze
umocníme vlastní hodnotu,
protože se dostane
do fáze horního qubit dvakrát, místo pouze jednou.
A takže když přemýšlíme o
výsledných pravděpodobnostech jako o funkci theta, v podstatě jen
zdvojnásobujeme frekvenci.
Pro každou možnou volbu theta jsou výsledné pravděpodobnosti
stejné, jaké by byly, kdybychom zdvojnásobili theta a poté
vzali desetinnou část
abychom dostali číslo mezi nulou a jednou.
Například, pokud theta
je rovno jedné polovině, pak vlastní hodnota je mínus jedna.
Takže dvojnásobnou aplikací U v podstatě umocníme vlastní hodnotu a výsledek je stejný, jako by byl pro theta rovná se nule.
Tedy pravděpodobnost
pro výsledek nula, zobrazená modře, je rovna jedné a pravděpodobnost pro výsledek jedna, zobrazená fialově, je rovna nule.
To je velmi jednoduché, ale ve skutečnosti tím můžeme získat
nějaké další informace o theta.
Například, pokud předem víme, že buď theta je rovno nule nebo theta rovná se jedné čtvrtině, pak tento circuit nám odhalí,
která z těchto dvou možností platí.
Na druhou stranu, již nelze rozlišit případ, kdy theta je rovno nule, od případu, kdy theta rovná se jedné polovině.
Takže tento postup není striktně lepší než ten předchozí, kdy jsme měli jediný řízený gate U, ale spuštěním tohoto circuit také
můžeme získat další informace.
Není okamžitě jasné,
jak lze dodatečné informace, které můžeme získat iterací řízené operace U vícekrát,
sladit s
informacemi, které získáme jejím provedením pouze jednou, a ve skutečnosti existuje několik
způsobů, jak bychom mohli postupovat.
Například existuje technika zvaná iterativní odhad fáze, která zahrnuje spouštění circuits, jako jsou ty, které jsme viděli,
spolu s několika drobnými variacemi na ně, k dosažení aproximace theta.
Ale popíšu
to, co by se dalo nazvat tradičnějším přístupem, kde používáme jediný kvantový circuit, který má více řídicích qubitů,
jež řídí různé
počty iterací unitární operace U.
Nejprve popíšu, jak to
funguje pro dva řídicí qubity a poté o něco později to zobecníme na více než dva řídicí qubity.
Zde je kvantový circuit,
který používá dva řídicí qubity.
Horní řídicí qubit
řídí jedinou operaci U, zatímco druhý qubit od shora řídí dvě kopie U.
Takže kombinujeme oba circuits, které jsme viděli dříve, způsobem, který využívá jedinou kopii
vlastního vektoru psi, který máme.
Všimneš si však,
že Hadamard gates po řízených operacích U
byly odstraněny a zatím nejsou žádná měření.
To, co uděláme, je
zjistit, jak tento circuit funguje, a pak přijdeme na to,
co bychom měli dělat s horními dvěma qubity,
abychom se dozvěděli co nejvíce o hodnotě theta, kterou
se pokoušíme aproximovat.
Po provedení Hadamard gates máme stav, který je
zobrazen na obrazovce.
WEBVTT
A toto bude pohodlný způsob zápisu stavu, abychom viděli, co se stane dál.
A nula a A jedna jsou bity, a pokud přemýšlíme o horních dvou qubitech jako o dvouqubitovém registru,
přemýšlíme o A nula, které odpovídá hornímu qubitu, jako o méně významném bitu, a A jedna, které odpovídá
spodnímu řídicímu qubitu,
jako o více významném bitu.
Po provedení první řízené
operace U získáme tento stav.
Klasický stav odpovídající hornímu řídicímu qubitu je A nula, takže výsledek phase kickback
lze vyjádřit tímto způsobem. Poté po druhé a
třetí řízené operaci U
získáme tento stav.
Myšlenka je stejná jako pro první operaci, jenomže tentokrát aplikujeme řízenou operaci U dvakrát.
Takže v exponentu násobíme A jedna dvěma,
abychom to zohlednili.
A nyní můžeme tento výraz zjednodušit přemýšlením o bitech
A jedna a A nula dohromady jako o celém čísle mezi nulou a
třemi pomocí binárního zápisu.
To znamená, když přemýšlíme
o dvoubitovém řetězci A jedna A nula jako o binárním
kódování celého čísla,
dostaneme dvě
krát A jedna plus A nula.
A rozumí se, že
když píšeme Cat X, mluvíme o X zapsaném jako binární řetězec délky
dvě v binárním zápisu.
Zaměřme se nyní na
tyto dva řídicí qubity, abychom zjistili, co
se z nich v tomto bodě můžeme dozvědět o theta.
Zbývajících N qubitů je
stále ve stejném stavu psi, který nám byl původně dán, což je skutečně nádherná
vlastnost tohoto přístupu,
protože jak jsem řekl dříve, tento stav můžeme znovu použít, pokud chceme získat ještě více
informací o theta.
Ale zatím jen přemýšlejme o tom, co se můžeme dozvědět z
těchto dvou řídicích qubitů.
Abychom si pomohli zjistit, jak postupovat, představme si, že je nám slíbeno, že theta je rovno Y děleno čtyřmi
pro nějaké celé číslo y mezi nulou a třemi.
Obecně theta nemusí
být jedna z těchto čtyř hodnot, ale toto je přirozený případ k uvažování.
Viděli jsme v původní verzi postupu s jediným řídicím qubitem, že pokud bylo slíbeno, že theta je buď nula nebo jedna polovina,
circuit by odhalil, která to je. A také jsme si všimli, že ve verzi, kde jsme aplikovali
řízenou operaci U dvakrát,
bychom mohli dokonale rozlišit případ theta rovná se nule od případu theta
rovná se jedné čtvrtině.
Takže bychom mohli doufat, že s naším novým circuitem dokážeme rozlišit tyto čtyři případy.
V podstatě
používáme pojem slibného problému,
aby byl problém jednodušší, takže vidíme, jak postupovat.
A to není špatný nápad obecně. Pokud máš problém a
nevíš, jak ho vyřešit, zkus ho zjednodušit.
Pokud dokážeš vyřešit jednodušší problém, může ti získaný vhled pomoci při řešení obecnějšího problému.
A pokud nedokážeš vyřešit jednodušší problém, pravděpodobně nejsi připraven
na obecnější problém.
Takže ho dál zjednodušuj,
dokud ho nevyřešíš.
Každopádně, vraťme se k našemu problému, definujme dvouqubitový stav pro každou z možných hodnot Y.
Jinými slovy, phi Y je rovno stavu
zobrazenému v horní části obrazovky, když je theta zvoleno
konkrétně jako Y děleno čtyřmi.
A zde jsou ty čtyři
stavy explicitně vypsány.
Tedy jen pro rekapitulaci, pokud
theta je rovno Y děleno čtyřmi pro Y rovné nule, jedné, dvěma nebo
třem a spustíme náš circuit,
zůstaneme s
jedním z těchto čtyř stavů, ten, který odpovídá
správné hodnotě Y.
A jen chceme zjistit,
který to je.
A otázka je, je to možné?
A odpověď na tuto otázku je ano, protože tyto čtyři stavy jsou ortogonální.
Pokud vypočítáš vnitřní součin
libovolného páru z nich, dostaneš nulu.
A protože jsou ortogonální, lze je dokonale rozlišit projektivním měřením.
A konkrétně takové měření můžeme
vyjádřit definováním jedné projekce pro každý vektor, jak zde máme.
Toto vždy funguje, kdykoli
máme ortonormální bázi, a pro tento konkrétní případ
to můžeš ověřit oproti definicím, které jsme viděli ve třetí lekci,
pokud máš zájem. Takže dospíváme k závěru, že je
možné splnit náš úkol,
což je zjistit hodnotu Y ze stavu zobrazeného
v horní části obrazovky.
A pokud to chceme udělat
pomocí kvantového circuit, můžeme postupovat tak, jak nyní vysvětlím.
Nejprve můžeme definovat unitární matici V, jejíž sloupce jsou čtyři
vektory seřazené v pořadí.
Tato matice bude mít na standardních bázových stavech
akci popsanou v dolní části obrazovky,
a matici si můžeme zapsat,
abychom viděli, jak vypadá.
Protože V zobrazuje každý standardní bázový stav kappa Y na vektor phi Y, máme, že aplikací V dagger,
neboli jinými slovy inverzního V na phi Y se transformujeme zpět na odpovídající standardní bázový stav.
WEBVTT
Takže to, co můžeme udělat, je aplikovat V dagger na libovolný stav, který
jsme získali z našeho circuit.
A pokud poté provedeme
měření ve standardní bázi, dostaneme číslo Y,
které hledáme, vyjádřené jako řetězec
délky dvě v binárním zápisu.
Než půjdeme dál, povídejme si trochu více
o unitární matici V.
Toto je speciální matice a
možná jsi ji už viděl dříve.
Je to matice přidružená
k lineární operaci na čtyřrozměrných vektorech známé jako diskrétní Fourierova transformace.
Přesněji řečeno, diskrétní Fourierova transformace může být definována pro libovolnou
kladnou celočíselnou dimenzi a za chvíli se na ni obecně podíváme.
A takto vypadá
konkrétně, když je dimenze rovna čtyřem.
O diskrétní Fourierově transformaci si můžeme myslet různými způsoby.
Můžeme o ní přemýšlet čistě abstraktně jako o lineárním zobrazení na vektorech, které lze vyjádřit maticí.
A také o ní můžeme přemýšlet
jako o výpočetním problému, kde dostaneme vektor a chceme vypočítat výsledek
aplikace tohoto lineárního zobrazení.
Ukazuje se, že jde o neuvěřitelně důležitý
výpočetní problém a existuje pro jeho řešení vysoce efektivní algoritmus,
známý jako rychlá Fourierova transformace.
Ve skutečnosti je to tak důležitý problém například ve zpracování signálů, že rychlá Fourierova
transformace je mnohými považována
za jeden z nejdůležitějších a nejvýznamnějších
algoritmů, které kdy byly objeveny.
Také o diskrétní Fourierově transformaci můžeme přemýšlet
jako o unitární kvantové operaci, která může být aplikována na
vektor kvantového stavu.
A když o ní takto přemýšlíme, nazýváme ji kvantovou Fourierovou
transformací nebo zkráceně QFT.
Matematicky vzato je to v podstatě totéž jako diskrétní Fourierova transformace, ale nazýváme ji kvantovou Fourierovou transformací,
jen abychom objasnili, že jde o operaci aplikovanou na vektor kvantového stavu.
Takže změňme název naší matice z V na QFT čtyři, aby odrážel skutečnost,
že operace, se kterou jsme přišli, je ve skutečnosti kvantová Fourierova transformace.
Zde je tedy úplný circuit pro zjištění hodnoty Y, když je slíbeno, že
theta se rovná Y děleno čtyřmi
pro Y rovné nule, jedné, dvěma nebo třem.
A jen abychom se ujistili, že je to jasné, aplikujeme inverzní
kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci, jinými slovy QFT čtyři dagger,
abychom jeden ze čtyř možných stavů zobrazili zpět na standardní bázový stav cat Y, takže Y můžeme obnovit měřením.
To je tedy circuit, který
dostaneme přemýšlením o slibné verzi problému
odhadu fáze, kde je slíbeno, že theta
je nula, jedna čtvrtina, jedna
polovina nebo tři čtvrtiny, ale nic nám nebrání
spustit tento circuit pro
libovolnou hodnotu theta.
A pokud to uděláme, zde
jsou pravděpodobnosti pro čtyři možné
výsledky, které dostaneme.
Každá ze čtyř možných
hodnot Y má svou vlastní barvu a graf nám říká,
jaké jsou pravděpodobnosti pro každou z nich jako funkce theta.
Takže například, pokud theta
je rovno třem čtvrtinám, dostaneme výsledek
tři s pravděpodobností jedna,
zatímco pravděpodobnosti pro ostatní tři výsledky jsou všechny nula, jak již víme z přemýšlení o slibné verzi problému.
Pokud je theta blízko třem čtvrtinám, ale není přesně tři čtvrtiny, bude s ostatními výsledky spojena nenulová pravděpodobnost,
ale stále dostaneme výsledek
tři s vysokou pravděpodobností.
Takže i když theta nemusí
být rovno Y děleno čtyřmi, stále si můžeme myslet
o výsledku, který dostaneme z měření, děleném čtyřmi,
jako o odhadu nebo
aproximaci pro theta.
Odhad může být chybný, ale přesto nám
poskytuje informace.
A jedna věc, kterou se
z grafu můžeme naučit, je, že nejlepší aproximace mají vždy nejvyšší
pravděpodobnosti s nimi spojené.
Když říkám nejlepší aproximace, myslím tím jakoukoli hodnotu Y děleno čtyřmi, která je nejblíže skutečné hodnotě theta,
v modulo jedna smyslu. Nejhorší možný případ je, že theta je přesně uprostřed mezi
dvěma hodnotami Y děleno čtyřmi.
Například, pokud theta je rovno
třem osminám nebo 0,375, v tomto případě vidíme,
že aproximace
jedna čtvrtina a dvě čtvrtiny
nebo jedna polovina jsou stejně dobré.
Takže v tomto konkrétním
případě jsou vlastně dvě nejlepší aproximace, nikoli jedna.
A výsledky jedna a dva
jsou stejně pravděpodobné.
Ostatní dva výsledky nula a tři, které neposkytují příliš dobrou
aproximaci theta po dělení čtyřmi, se skutečně vyskytují s určitou pravděpodobností,
která se zdá být těsně
pod 10 % v obou případech.
Takže tento postup není dokonalý, ale poskytuje nám informace.
A je pozoruhodné, že
bez ohledu na theta máme vždy zaručeno, že vylosujeme buď nejlepší aproximaci
nebo jednu z dvou nejlepších aproximací, pokud je remíza, s pravděpodobností,
která se zdá být těsně nad 40 %.
WEBVTT
A čím blíže je theta k aproximaci, tím vyšší je pravděpodobnost, že uvidíme odpovídající hodnotu Y.
A to je poměrně
výrazné zlepšení oproti použití jediného řídicího qubitu.
Toto je vlastně postup odhadu fáze, když se rozhodujeme použít dva řídicí qubity.
A to, co uděláme dál, je přirozeným způsobem zobecnit tento
postup, kde se nezastavíme
pouze u dvou řídicích qubitů,
ale použijeme libovolný počet
řídicích qubitů.
A uvidíme, že
zobecněním postupu přidáváním dalších řídicích qubitů budeme schopni získávat stále přesnější
aproximace theta. A to bude obecný
postup odhadu fáze.
Aby bylo možné zobecnit
postup odhadu fáze ze dvou řídicích qubitů
na libovolný počet, budeme muset pochopit,
jak je kvantová Fourierova transformace definována pro jiné dimenze.
A také budeme muset probrat, jak ji lze implementovat
pomocí kvantového circuit.
Zde je definice
kvantové Fourierovy transformace, když je dimenze libovolné kladné celé číslo N.
Zde přemýšlíme o této operaci jako o operaci na systému, jehož klasické stavy jsou
nula až N mínus jedna.
A zde byla matice popisující tuto operaci vyjádřena
pomocí přímého zápisu.
Lze ji také popsat z hlediska jejího působení
na standardní bázové stavy, jen abychom to propojili s
tím, co jsme již viděli, když N je rovno čtyřem.
Takto tedy vypadá,
když N je rovno jedné, což není příliš zajímavý případ.
Zde je pro N rovno dvěma a všimneš si, že v tomto případě dostaneme operaci Hadamard.
Zde je kvantová Fourierova
transformace pro N rovné třem.
Pro N rovné čtyřem, které
jsme již viděli.
A pro poslední příklad, zde je pro N rovno osmi.
Stejně jako dříve
pro případ N rovné čtyřem, jsou to matice, které přiřazujeme diskrétní Fourierově transformaci
pro každou z dimenzí. Ale nazýváme ji
kvantovou Fourierovou transformací, když o ní chceme přemýšlet
jako o kvantové operaci.
Mimochodem, přední faktor jedna děleno odmocninou z N někdy není zahrnut, když přemýšlíme o diskrétní Fourierově
transformaci jako o matici,
ale tento faktor zde potřebujeme, abychom se ujistili, že dostaneme unitární matici.
Někdy bývá také znaménko mínus v každém z exponentů, ale ne vždy.
V podstatě je to jen osobní preference, která nemění základní
povahu transformace.
Ale v každém případě definujeme kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci tak, jak je zde napsáno na obrazovce.
Existuje velmi užitečná zkrácená
notace, která je běžná a použijeme ji
trochu později v lekci.
A sice definovat
komplexní číslo omega N, jak ho máme zde.
Konkrétně jako e na dvě pí I děleno N, které lze také zapsat
pomocí sinů a kosinů,
jak máme právě zde. Někdy toto
číslo nazýváme N-tým kořenem z jedničky, protože když ho umocníme
na N, dostaneme jedničku.
Zde je obrázek ukazující několik příkladů.
Omega jedna je rovna jedné, omega dvě je rovna mínus jedné a omega čtyři je rovna I.
Obecně, abychom dostali omega N, si můžeme představit, jak rozdělujeme jednotkovou kružnici na N stejně velkých dílků, jako pizza sdílená N lidmi,
a omega N je v
rohu prvního dílku za předpokladu, že druhý roh
tohoto dílku je u jedničky.
Takže konkrétně, jak N
roste stále větší, dílky budou stále menší a omega N se bude
přibližovat stále blíže k jedné.
A nyní, pokud tuto notaci použijeme, můžeme kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci vyjádřit trochu přehledněji.
Tato notace někdy
pomáhá udržet věci jednoduché, jak uvidíme
trochu později v lekci.
Existuje efektivní implementace kvantového circuit
pro kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci,
když je N mocninou dvou,
na kterou se nyní podíváme. Ačkoli kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci obvykle definujeme pro libovolnou dimenzi N,
budeme ji potřebovat pouze
v případě, kdy N je mocnina dvou, abychom mohli zobecnit
postup odhadu fáze.
Implementace bude využívat řízené phase gates, které jsou zobrazeny tak, jak
je zde na obrazovce.
Vypadají jako dvě
propojené řídicí linky spolu s číslem, které
je v tomto případě alfa.
A akce tohoto gate je popsána maticí, která je zde uvedena.
Jsou to doslova
řízené phase gates, což znamená, že máme řídicí qubit, který řídí phase gate.
Phase gates jsme viděli již v první lekci.
Ale pro phase gates konkrétně ve skutečnosti nezáleží na tom,
který qubit je řídicí a který je cílový.
To jsme viděli ve druhé lekci, pro konkrétní případ Z gate.
A nyní, když máme tuto představu, můžeme přejít k tomu, jak lze
kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci implementovat.
WEBVTT
Implementace je rekurzivní povahy a snad nejjednodušší způsob, jak ji popsat jednoduše, je uvést příklad, který
lze snadno zobecnit.
Takto to uděláme,
když N je rovno 32.
Takže je pět qubitů.
Pro jasnost, přiřazujeme
standardní bázové stavy těchto pěti qubitů celým číslům mezi nulou a 31 pomocí binárního zápisu.
První věc, kterou uděláme, je provést kvantovou Fourierovu
transformaci pro N rovné 16 na všechny qubity kromě
qubitu s nejmenší významností,
což je ten nahoře. A to je rekurzivní
část konstrukce.
Abychom implementovali tuto operaci, musíme postupovat podle stejného
vzoru, ale s o jeden qubit méně.
A v základním případě máme
pouze jediný qubit, pro který je kvantová Fourierova transformace jen Hadamard gate.
Jakmile aplikujeme QFT na všechny qubity kromě horního, aplikujeme řadu řízených phase gates s fázemi, které jsou
naznačeny v diagramu.
Poté aplikujeme Hadamard
gate na horní qubit a qubity trochu přesuneme pomocí několika swap gates.
Tyto swap gates mají efekt cyklické permutace qubitů, která je potřebná, aby
konstrukce fungovala.
Pro jiné volby N, pokud jsou mocninami dvou, můžeme postupovat úplně stejně, přičemž vždy začínáme řízené phase gates
s alfa rovným pí děleno
dvěma pro spodní qubit a dělíme dvěma pokaždé,
když se pohybujeme vlevo v diagramu,
abychom dostali následné fáze. Nyní vůbec není zřejmé,
že tato konstrukce funguje.
A v tomto videu nevysvětlím,
proč to funguje.
Pokud tě zajímají
detaily, proč to funguje, najdeš je v
písemném obsahu lekce.
Řeknu však, že
to, co je zde využíváno, je základní struktura
diskrétních Fourierových transformací,
a ve skutečnosti je to přesně
tatáž struktura, která umožňuje fungovat rychlé
Fourierově transformaci.
Jiný způsob, jak to říct, je, že pokud se podíváme na rychlou Fourierovu transformaci, můžeme o ní přemýšlet
z hlediska kvantových circuits.
A toto je circuit, který dostaneme.
Kolik gates tedy celkem potřebujeme pro tuto implementaci?
Abychom to zjistili, označme SM jako počet gates,
které potřebujeme, když máme M qubitů.
Když M je rovno jedné, potřebujeme pouze jediný gate, protože QFT je v tomto případě jen operace Hadamard.
Pokud M je alespoň dvě, pak jsou to
gates, které potřebujeme.
Nejprve potřebujeme SM mínus jedna gates pro kvantovou Fourierovu
transformaci na M mínus jedna qubitech, ať je to jakékoli číslo.
Také potřebujeme M mínus jedna
řízených phase gates, M mínus jedna swap gates,
a jeden další Hadamard gate.
Zde je tedy výraz
SM v obou případech, když M je rovno jedné a
když M je alespoň dvě.
Toto je příklad toho, čemu se říká rekurentní relace a
v analýze algoritmů se vyskytují velmi běžně.
Tato konkrétní
je velmi jednoduchá a má tzv.
uzavřenou formu výrazu, který lze získat sečtením.
Přesněji řečeno, hodnota SM je součet prvních M
po sobě jdoucích lichých přirozených čísel, což se rovná M na druhou,
jak jsi možná buď již narazil na tento výsledek nebo sis toho možná sám všiml
v nějakém bodě svého života.
A tento vzorec je poměrně snadné dokázat indukcí na M,
pokud tě formální důkaz zajímá.
A to je vše. Kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci na M qubitech lze implementovat pomocí M na druhou gates.
Jen pár velmi
stručných dalších poznámek.
Za prvé, ve skutečnosti
nepotřebujeme všechny swap gates, které jsem popsal.
Je možné je efektivně
všechny přesunout na konec, pokud upravíme, na které qubity řízené phase gates
působí, vhodným způsobem.
A pokud to uděláme, budeme potřebovat pouze
M děleno dvěma swap gates celkem, zaokrouhleno dolů.
Stále budeme mít kvadratické náklady, ale počet gates lze takto přesto snížit.
A jedna závěrečná poznámka je, že náklady mohou být ještě nižší, pokud jsme ochotni se spokojit s
poměrně dobrou aproximací.
Například, když M roste, mnoho řízených phase gates je poměrně blízko
operaci identity,
a eliminace
těch, které jsou velmi blízko, nám může ušetřit poměrně hodně na gates a přitom nám stále dát
poměrně dobrou aproximaci.
Je také možné aproximovat kvantovou Fourierovu transformaci
velmi mělkými circuits, tedy těmi s malou hloubkou, pokud je to
něco, co chceme dělat.
A nyní, když víme, co je kvantová Fourierova transformace pro různé dimenze, i to, jak ji lze implementovat, když je dimenze mocnina dvou,
se můžeme vrátit k
postupu odhadu fáze a zjistit, jak ho lze zobecnit, kde použijeme libovolný
počet M řídicích qubitů.
Takto vypadá postup jako kvantový circuit pro
libovolnou volbu M.
Máme M řídicích qubitů nahoře, o kterých předpokládáme, že jsou všechny
inicializovány do stavu nula.
Na každý z nich aplikujeme Hadamard
gate a poté každý z nich slouží jako řídicí qubit pro aplikaci nějaké mocniny
unitární operace U,
WEBVTT
přičemž pro každý řídicí qubit zdvojnásobujeme počet
aplikací U.
V tomto diagramu jsem to naznačil zahrnutím mocnin
u U uvnitř políček, místo zobrazení řízeného U gate,
aplikovaného tolikrát, jako způsob jak
diagram zpřehlednit a ušetřit místo, aby se
vešel na obrazovku.
Nyní první věc, které si musíme u
tohoto postupu všimnout, je, že může být velmi nákladný.
Konkrétně
zdvojnásobujeme počet aplikací každé operace U
pro každý řídicí qubit.
A pokud to děláme jednoduše iterací řízeného U gate tolikrát, kolikrát potřebujeme,
dostaneme obrovský circuit. Bude exponenciálně
velký v počtu M.
To je obecně velké omezení a zejména to omezuje naši schopnost získávat přesné aproximace
vlastních hodnot.
Ale v konkrétním případě faktorizace, ke které se brzy dostaneme, máme velké štěstí a můžeme použít trik, který nám umožňuje
vyhnout se tomuto exponenciálnímu nárůstu nákladů.
Ale obecně pro libovolné
unitární operace U to nebude možné a
zaplatíme vysokou cenu
za zvyšování
počtu řídicích qubitů.
V tomto videu neprojdu
podrobnou analýzou circuit, ale zmíním, že existuje poměrně jednoduchý
výraz pro stav
těsně před měřeními, který je zde na obrazovce.
Z tohoto stavu můžeme získat výraz pro pravděpodobnosti
různých výsledků, který vypadá takto.
A jakmile máme tento výraz,
můžeme o něm uvažovat, a tento výraz
je vše, co potřebujeme pro pokračování.
Jak jsem říkal, v tomto videu se do
detailů nevydám, ale najdeš je v
písemném obsahu lekce a ukazuje se, že to vlastně není tak složité,
takže se na to podívej, pokud tě to zajímá. Pokud analýzou projdeme, zjistíme, že situace
se příliš neliší
od případu M rovné dvěma, až na to, že dostáváme větší přesnost.
Konkrétně si nejprve můžeme
přemýšlet o pravděpodobnosti dostat tu úplně nejlepší nebo jednu z
dvou nejlepších aproximací,
kterou můžeme vyjádřit tak, jak máme zde.
Tento dolní index jedna u absolutní hodnoty si můžeš ignorovat, pokud chceš.
Jde jen o symbol, který
můžeme použít, abychom si připomněli, že mluvíme o
aproximacích na kružnici, kde přemýšlíme o theta rovném nule
a theta rovném jedné jako o totožných. Jde o to, že
přemýšlíme o jakékoli volbě Y, která činí Y děleno dvěma na mocninu M
co nejblíže k theta.
A opět, stejně jako jsme
měli pro případ M rovné dvěma, máme zaručeno, že dostaneme výsledek Y s pravděpodobností alespoň 40 %.
Ve skutečnosti je pravděpodobnost
alespoň čtyři děleno pí na druhou, což je trochu více než 40 %.
10 není špatná
aproximace pí na druhou, když se spěchá.
A to je ve skutečnosti poměrně pozoruhodné. Mluvíme o získání té úplně nejlepší
aproximace theta jako zlomku Y děleno dvěma na mocninu M,
kde Y je celé číslo. A tuto
úplně nejlepší aproximaci dostáváme s pravděpodobností větší než 40 %.
Také si můžeme přemýšlet o
horších aproximacích.
Konkrétně si představme,
že Y není tak dobré, a konkrétněji předpokládejme,
že existuje lepší
aproximace theta stejné formy, která leží mezi theta a Y děleno dvěma na M,
což lze vyjádřit, jak
je napsáno na obrazovce.
V takovém případě bude
pravděpodobnost dostat toto Y relativně malá, nejvýše 25 %.
Ve skutečnosti bude nižší než to, ale 25 % dostaneme z
poměrně jednoduché analýzy, a to stačí.
Jako příklad. Zde je graf, který dostaneme, když použijeme tři řídicí
qubity místo dvou.
Tentokrát vykresluji pouze
pravděpodobnosti pro výsledky tři, čtyři a pět, protože nechci, aby byl
obrázek příliš nepřehledný.
Když theta je rovno
jedné polovině například, máme zaručeno, že dostaneme výsledek čtyři.
A tedy naši
aproximaci vezmeme jako čtyři osminy nebo jedna polovina, protože dvě na
mocninu tři je osm.
A v tomto případě jsme přesně správně. A dokud je theta blíže jedné polovině než třem
osminám například,
dostaneme výsledek čtyři s pravděpodobností vyšší
než výsledek tři.
A s pravděpodobností
opět větší než 40 %.
Zde je graf, když M je rovno čtyřem. A křivky ve skutečnosti
vypadají téměř identicky, až na to, že nyní jsme přiblížili
o faktor dvě.
Takže nyní vykreslené výsledky zahrnují sedm, osm a devět a aproximaci bereme jako jedno z těchto čísel
děleno šestnácti, nikoli osmi.
A ukážu ještě jeden graf, kde zvýšíme na M rovné pěti.
A opět přiblížíme
o faktor dvě.
A zde je. Křivky opět vypadají
téměř identicky, ale efektivně
zdvojnásobujeme naši přesnost.
WEBVTT
A jako předtím dostáváme úplně nejlepší aproximaci theta s pravděpodobností větší než 40 %.
To je docela úžasné. Ale pokud 40 % není dostatečná
míra spolehlivosti,
můžeme postup spustit malý počet krát a
vzít modus výsledků, tedy ten, který
se vyskytuje nejčastěji.
A pokud to uděláme, bude velmi pravděpodobné, že skončíme s velmi dobrou aproximací theta.
Pamatuj mimochodem, že pokaždé, když spustíme
postup odhadu fáze, máme, že vlastní vektor
zůstane nezměněn.
Takže je k dispozici pro opakované
spuštění postupu
tímto způsobem.
Stručně řečeno, sbíráme
statistiky o theta a jde o to, že tímto způsobem můžeme získat velmi přesnou
aproximaci theta
s velmi vysokou spolehlivostí a k tomu nepotřebujeme příliš mnoho iterací postupu.
A tak funguje postup
odhadu fáze.
V poslední části lekce aplikujeme techniku
odhadu fáze na problém faktorizace celých čísel.
Jak jsem zmínil na začátku videa, funguje to tak, že uvažujeme o přechodném problému známém jako problém hledání řádu.
Uvidíme, jak můžeme vyřešit
problém hledání řádu pomocí odhadu fáze, a poté stručně probereme, jak řešení problému hledání řádu
umožňuje efektivně faktorizovat celá čísla.
Druhá část je zcela klasická a v tomto videu shrnu pouze
základní myšlenku.
Ale začněme
problémem hledání řádu.
Nejprve si zavedeme
přehlednou notaci.
Pro každé kladné celé číslo N definujeme ZN jako celá čísla
nula až N mínus jedna.
Takže například Z jedna má
jediný prvek, kterým je nula, Z dvě má prvky nula a jedna,
Z tři má prvky nula,
jedna a dvě a tak dále.
Takže ZN je množina.
Ale můžeme o ní přemýšlet
i jako o více než množině. Můžeme přemýšlet o aritmetických operacích jako sčítání a násobení na ZN,
definovaných modulo N.
Například předpokládejme,
že N je rovno sedmi.
Máme, že tři a pět
jsou prvky Z sedm a pokud je vynásobíme, dostaneme 15,
což nám po dělení sedmi
dá zbytek jedna.
Někdy to vyjadřujeme zápisem, že tři krát pět je
kongruentní jedné modulo sedm, jak je zde zapsáno.
Ale také můžeme jednoduše psát, že tři krát pět se rovná jedné.
Samozřejmě tři krát pět
normálně není rovno jedné, ale je rovno 15.
Ale když je jasné, že
pracujeme v Z sedm, tedy že násobení
je definováno modulo sedm,
pak jednoduše napíšeme, že
tři krát pět se rovná jedné.
Nyní, mezi prvky
ZN pro libovolné kladné N, některé z nich budou mít
GCD rovné jedné s N
a některé ne. A prvky, které mají GCD rovné jedné s N, jsou speciální.
a píšeme ZN hvězdička, abychom odkazovali na množinu právě těchto prvků.
Takže například, zde je Z 21 hvězdička.
Mezi prvky Z 21, kterých je samozřejmě 21, se ukazuje, že 12 z nich má GCD rovné jedné
s 21 a zbytek ne.
Konkrétně kdykoli máme prvek Z 21, který je dělitelný buď
třemi nebo sedmi, přeskočíme ho.
Existují různé důvody,
proč je tato množina speciální, a jedním z důvodů je, že kdykoli máme prvek ZN hvězdička,
a uvažujeme kladné
celočíselné mocniny tohoto čísla, vždy nakonec
dosáhneme čísla jedna,
přičemž stejně jako dříve mluvíme o násobení modulo N.
nejmenší kladná celočíselná mocnina, která nám dá jedničku, se nazývá
řád tohoto prvku.
Například uvažujme prvek A rovný čtyřem v Z 21 hvězdička.
čtyři krát čtyři je 16, což není rovno jedné modulo 21, ale pokud vynásobíme čtyřmi ještě jednou,
dostaneme 64 a 64 modulo
21 se rovná jedné.
Takže řád čtyři modulo 21 je tři.
Dosažení jedničky tímto způsobem vždy nastane pro všechny prvky ZN hvězdička.
A mimochodem, nikdy
k tomu nedojde pro prvky ZN, které nejsou v ZN hvězdička.
Takže mít GCD rovné
jedné s N takto je jak nutnou, tak
dostatečnou podmínkou pro to, aby k tomu došlo.
A jen abychom dokončili
příklad N rovné 21, zde jsou nejmenší
kladné celočíselné mocniny, pro které toto funguje pro
každý prvek Z 21 hvězdička,
a každý z nich lze ověřit jeden po druhém.
A nyní můžeme formulovat
problém hledání řádu, který jednoduše spočívá v nalezení řádu daného prvku v ZN hvězdička.
WEBVTT
Přesněji řečeno, vstupem jsou
dvě kladná celá čísla A a N, pro která je GCD rovno jedné,
a výstupem je
nejmenší kladné celé číslo R takové, že A na mocninu R je
kongruentní jedné modulo N,
nebo ekvivalentně
nejmenší kladné celé číslo R, pro které A na R se rovná jedné.
Za předpokladu, že provádíme aritmetiku v ZN.
Předpokládá se, že jde o
výpočetně náročný problém, není znám žádný efektivní klasický algoritmus
pro jeho řešení.
A jak probereme, problém je alespoň tak těžký jako
faktorizace celých čísel v tom smyslu, že pokud máme algoritmus pro řešení hledání řádu,
mohli bychom tento algoritmus použít k efektivnímu řešení problému
faktorizace celých čísel.
Ve skutečnosti to platí i obráceně, tedy pokud máš náhodou algoritmus pro faktorizaci, můžeš ho použít k řešení
problému hledání řádu.
Takže oba problémy jsou
v jistém smyslu ekvivalentní z hlediska jejich
výpočetní náročnosti.
Nyní uvidíme, jak můžeme vyřešit
problém hledání řádu na kvantovém počítači
pomocí odhadu fáze.
Abychom propojili tyto problémy, představme si, že máme systém, jehož klasická stavová množina je AN.
Pro jakoukoli volbu prvku A v ZN hvězdička definujeme operaci
MA, jak máme zde.
Slovy, MA provádí násobení A, přičemž násobení je modulo N.
A pro zbytek této lekce bys měl vždy přemýšlet o
výrazech uvnitř catů jako o vypočítaných modulo N,
abychom mohli udržet věci jednoduché a nemuseli stále
psát mod N znovu a znovu.
Toto je unitární operace, ale to platí pouze
tehdy, když A je v ZN hvězdička.
Pokud GCD A a N není jedna, tato operace nebude unitární.
Zde je příklad. Pokud N je rovno 15 a A je rovno dvěma, což je v Z 15 hvězdička, pak
toto je akce M dvě.
A pokud tento
příklad chvíli prozkoumáš, uvidíš, že to, co se děje, je, že prvky ZN jsou touto akcí jednoduše permutovány.
Takže je to deterministické i unitární, což znamená, že jako matice je MA permutační maticí.
A zde je hlavní myšlenka. Vlastní hodnoty MA jsou
velmi úzce spjaty
s řádem A. A použitím odhadu fáze k dostatečně přesnému přiblížení těchto
vlastních hodnot
můžeme určit řád A. Jaké jsou tedy přesně vlastní vektory a vlastní hodnoty MA?
Nepotřebujeme je všechny, potřebujeme pouze některé z nich.
Začněme jednoduchým příkladem.
Zde je vlastní vektor MA, pojmenovali jsme ho psi nula, a je dán součtem cat jedna, cat a,
cat A na druhou a tak dále až po cat A na mocninu R mínus jedna, vše děleno odmocninou z R,
aby byl jednotkovým vektorem. Zde R je řád A.
A písmeno R si vyhradím
pro řád A pro zbytek lekce.
Takže kdykoli uvidíš R, je to řád A pro
jakékoli A, o kterém mluvíme.
Vlastní hodnota přidružená
k tomuto vlastnímu vektoru je jedna.
A to lze ověřit
aplikací MA na tento vektor, abychom viděli, co dostaneme.
MA násobí A, takže
stačí zvýšit každý z exponentů o
jedničku a toto dostaneme.
Ale řád A je R, takže A na mocninu R se rovná jedné.
A tuto substituci můžeme provést.
Ale to je stejný vektor,
se kterým jsme začali. Vše, co jsme udělali, je přeskládání catů, ale bereme součet, takže
to nic nemění.
Takže MA krát psi nula se rovná psi nula.
Takže je to vlastní vektor
MA s vlastní hodnotou jedna.
To je velmi jednoduchý
příklad vlastního vektoru a abychom identifikovali více z nich, připomeňme si stejnou notaci, kterou jsme měli dříve v lekci.
Omega R je komplexní
číslo na jednotkové kružnici, které dostaneme dosazením E na
mocninu dvě krát pí krát I
děleno R. Naposledy jsme měli N místo R, ale funguje to stejně
pro R místo N.
Toto číslo potřebujeme, protože
se bude vyskytovat v ostatních vlastních vektorech
MA, které identifikujeme.
A nyní, když jsme tuto notaci připomněli, můžeme pozorovat, že
vektor pojmenovaný psi jedna je také vlastním vektorem MA.
Je podobný psi nula, máme přesně stejné caty a sčítáme je a
dělíme odmocninou z R.
Ale tentokrát máme různé fáze násobící každý cat.
Omega R na mínus jedna pro A, omega R na mínus dvě pro A na druhou a tak dále až po omega R na
mocninu mínus R mínus jedna
pro A na mocninu R mínus jedna. Takže mocnina omega R
je vždy mínus jedna krát jakoukoli mocninu A
se vyskytující uvnitř catu.
Neprojdu to podrobně, ale je to zobrazeno na obrazovce, pokud by sis chtěl video přehrát znovu a podle potřeby pozastavit.
Ale pokud provedeme násobení a znovu zjednodušíme pomocí skutečnosti, že A na mocninu R se rovná jedné,
a také velmi důležité skutečnosti, že omega na mocninu R se rovná jedné, zjistíme, že
opět máme vlastní vektor MA.
WEBVTT
Tentokrát při zjednodušování budeme muset vytknout faktor omega R, abychom viděli, že skutečně máme vlastní vektor,
a tento vektor omega R představuje vlastní hodnotu přidruženou k tomuto vlastnímu vektoru.
To je tedy druhý pár vlastní vektor
vlastní hodnota NA.
Další vlastní vektory můžeme identifikovat pomocí naprosto stejného uvažování, a ve skutečnosti, pokud jednoduše nahradíme omega R
za omega R na mocninu J pro každé J mezi nulou a R mínus jedna, vždy dostaneme vlastní vektor,
a přidružená vlastní hodnota bude omega R na mocninu J.
Takže to ve skutečnosti zahrnuje
psi nula a psi jedna, které jsme již viděli,
stejně jako R mínus dva dalších párů vlastní vektor, vlastní hodnota.
Všechny fungují v podstatě stejně a pro jejich ověření stačí vědět, že A na mocninu R se rovná jedné,
stejně jako omega R na
mocninu R se rovná jedné.
Existují i jiné vlastní vektory MA, například cat nula, ale ty nebudou pro nás užitečné a nemusíme se jimi zabývat.
Stačí nám zabývat se psi nula až psi R mínus jedna.
Zaměřme se na chvíli na psi jedna, abychom se pokusili pochopit, proč nám tyto vlastní vektory jsou důležité
a co nám mohou říct
o řádu R, který se pokoušíme najít.
Předpokládejme, že dostaneme
vlastní vektor psi jedna, můžeme se pokusit zjistit
R následujícím způsobem.
Nejprve provedeme odhad
fáze na tomto vlastním vektoru pomocí kvantového circuit, který
implementuje operaci MA.
Dostaneme aproximaci theta, což je v tomto případě jedna děleno R.
A za druhé, protože hledáme R a máme
aproximaci jedné děleno R, přirozená věc je
vypočítat převrácenou hodnotu
a zaokrouhlit na
nejbližší celé číslo. Musíme zaokrouhlovat takto,
protože R musí být celé číslo.
Ale nemáme přesně jednu děleno R, máme jen aproximaci.
Pokud je ale aproximace dostatečně dobrá, dostaneme R po zaokrouhlení,
což hledáme.
A nyní otázkou je, jakou přesnost potřebujeme ke správnému určení R výpočtem převrácené hodnoty a zaokrouhlením?
Jinými slovy, jak přesná musí být naše
aproximace, aby toto všechno fungovalo?
No, ukazuje se, že potřebujeme poměrně přesnou aproximaci.
Například nemůžeme si dovolit zaměnit jednu děleno R za jednu děleno R plus jedna, nebo jednu děleno R mínus jedna například.
V těchto dvou zlomcích je jedna děleno R plus jedna a
jedna děleno R mínus jedna poměrně blízko jedné
děleno R, když je R velké.
Ale i když potřebujeme
poměrně přesnou aproximaci, nepotřebujeme směšně
přesnou aproximaci a lze ukázat, že pokud naše aproximace
splňuje nerovnost, kterou
máme zde na obrazovce, pak zaokrouhlení
nám dá správnou odpověď.
V tomto videu se o to nebudu pokoušet argumentovat, ale je to ukázáno v písemném
materiálu lekce, pokud tě zajímají detaily.
A pokud je to přesnost,
o kterou usilujeme, pak stačí použít počet řídicích qubitů v postupu odhadu fáze,
který se rovná dvěma násobkům
délky N plus jedna.
Kde, jak jsme měli v předchozích lekcích, délka N je počet bitů, které potřebujeme k vyjádření N v binárním zápisu.
Mimochodem, pokud jsme spokojeni
s tím, že dostaneme nejlepší aproximaci s pravděpodobností alespoň 40 % a nepokoušíme se
zvýšit naši spolehlivost,
jak jsem popsal dříve, pak plus jedna vlastně nepotřebujeme.
Ale v každém případě máme, že počet
řídicích qubitů, které potřebujeme, je lineární v délce N
zapsaného jako binární řetězec.
Viděli jsme, že pokud máme
vlastní vektor psi jedna, můžeme použít odhad fáze k nalezení R za předpokladu, že použijeme dostatečnou přesnost.
Bohužel není tak snadné dostat tento vlastní vektor do rukou.
Položme si tedy jinou otázku.
Předpokládejme, že nemáme psi jedna, ale spíše psi
pro náhodnou volbu J.
Dokážeme stále zjistit, jaké R je? Nebo přinejmenším dokážeme
zjistit něco o R?
A odpověď je ano, dokážeme zjistit něco
o R, alespoň průměrně.
To, co můžeme udělat, je pokusit se
zjistit J děleno R pomocí velmi podobné metody
k té, kterou jsme právě viděli,
ale s klíčovým rozdílem.
Nejprve uděláme přesně
totéž, co jsme dělali dříve, tedy spustíme postup
odhadu fáze na vlastním vektoru psi J.
A dostaneme
aproximaci J děleno R, na rozdíl od jedné děleno R,
kterou jsme měli dříve.
Ale nyní máme malý problém, protože výpočet
převrácené hodnoty nám nedá R, ale R děleno J.
A mimochodem, nepředpokládáme, že víme, jaké J je, jednoduše dostaneme psi J pro náhodné J,
a nejsme informováni, jaké J je. Tak co můžeme dělat?
No, ukazuje se, že existuje dobře známý
klasický algoritmus, který nám může pomoci, nazývaný
algoritmus řetězových zlomků.
A to, co tento algoritmus dokáže, je vzít naši aproximaci
Y děleno dvě na M a říct nám, který zlomek U děleno V,
zapsaný v základním tvaru a kde U a V jsou obě
celá čísla menší než N, je nejblíže naší aproximaci.
WEBVTT
Je to opravdu fascinující algoritmus, a pokud tě zajímá, určitě se na něj podívej.
Ve skutečnosti je velmi úzce spjat s Euklidovým algoritmem pro
výpočet GCD.
Ale v tomto videu o něm
neřeknu nic víc.
Jde o to, že pokud máme dobrou
aproximaci nějakého zlomku, jehož čitatel a
jmenovatel nejsou příliš velké,
algoritmus dokáže zlomek obnovit, a to je to, co zde děláme.
A nyní nám zbývá přesně
tatáž otázka jako předtím, tedy jakou přesnost potřebujeme?
A ukazuje se, že
přesně stejná hranice, kterou jsme měli dříve, funguje i v tomto případě.
A tedy volba M přesně
stejným způsobem jako dříve funguje i zde.
Nyní to nemusí nutně
říct nám R.
To, co se dozvíme, pokud použijeme
dostatečnou přesnost, je J děleno R, ale to bude
zlomek v základním tvaru.
Takže bychom mohli mít smůlu v tom smyslu, že tato náhodná volba J může mít společné faktory s R,
a budou před námi skryty. V nejhorším případě například bychom mohli dostat J rovné nule a nedozvíme se absolutně nic.
Ale to je doslova jediný
případ, kdy se nic nedozvíme.
Obecně dostaneme alespoň
netriviální faktor R, a pokud jsme schopni získávat náhodné vzorky
a dostat psi J pro různé volby J, dokážeme ve skutečnosti obnovit
R s vysokou pravděpodobností výpočtem nejmenšího společného násobku
všech jmenovatelů,
které pozorujeme. A to vlastně nevyžaduje
příliš mnoho vzorků.
Závěr je, že některé volby J skryjí faktory R, ale náhodné volby J
nebudou schopny skrývat
faktory R příliš dlouho.
To je tedy celá myšlenka. Zbývá zvážit implementaci a zejména zjistit,
jaké jsou náklady.
Podstata myšlenky, výpočet řádu daného prvku A a ZN hvězdička, spočívá v aplikaci postupu odhadu fáze
na operaci MA.
Zjistíme, jaké
jsou náklady na toto jako funkce délky velkého N, kterou označím malým n.
Zde je circuit pro odhad fáze. Budeme potřebovat malé n qubitů ve spodní části circuit,
abychom zakódovali prvky ZN v binárním zápisu. Takže máme N řídicích qubitů nahoře a malé n qubitů dole,
což je pěkné, protože to odpovídá názvům, které jsme
použili dříve v lekci.
Abychom spočítali
celkový počet gates, které potřebujeme pro celý circuit, zaměřme se nejprve na náklady řízených unitárních operací.
Pokud použijeme techniky
z předchozí lekce, lekce šest, dokážeme implementovat MA pomocí O velkého malého n na druhou gates,
využitím efektivních klasických algoritmů pro aritmetiku modulo N.
V tomto videu vynechám detaily, ale stejně jako u několika dalších věcí, o kterých jsem mluvil, si o tom můžeš přečíst více v písemném materiálu lekce.
Nestačí však
implementovat pouze MA.
Musíme také implementovat MA na druhou, MA na čtvrtou, na osmou a tak dále,
až po MA na mocninu, která je exponenciální v M.
A víme, že M musíme vzít jako lineární v malém n,
abychom získali dostatečnou přesnost.
To je vážný problém,
a zmínil jsem ho dříve.
Kdybychom implementovali mocniny
MA pouhým iterováním MA, měli bychom problém, protože všechny tyto iterace MA
by způsobily exponenciální náklady.
Naštěstí můžeme použít trik, jak se tomuto nárůstu nákladů vyhnout.
To, co můžeme udělat, je následující, pro každou mocninu K, kterou potřebujeme.
Nejprve vypočítáme A na
mocninu K, modulo N.
Toto je problém modulárního umocňování, který jsem zmínil v šesté lekci.
A lze ho efektivně vyřešit. A to je něco, co můžeme udělat pomocí klasického počítače.
Tento výpočet vůbec
nemusí být prováděn kvantovým circuitem.
Nechť tedy B je výsledek.
Takže B je prvek ZN hvězdička.
A za druhé, místo MA na mocninu K jednoduše použijeme circuit pro MB.
A to je vše. B je jen nějaký prvek ZN hvězdička, takže náklady na implementaci MB
jsou O velkého malého n na druhou.
Stručně řečeno, umocňujeme v ZN místo umocňování
kvantového circuit.
Ale skutečná operace, kterou
dostaneme, je v obou případech stejná. Je to jen násobení A, K-krát.
Toto je ve skutečnosti zázrak. A kdybychom neměli tuto možnost, nedokázali bychom
vyřešit problém hledání řádu nebo efektivně faktorizovat celá čísla
na kvantovém počítači.
pokud by to nebylo možné.
A nyní, když víme, že každou z řízených
unitárních operací, včetně mocnin, lze implementovat
s náklady O velkého n na druhou, můžeme spočítat celkový
počet gates, které potřebujeme.
Máme N Hadamard gates a protože M se rovná O velkého malého n, náklady jsou O velkého malého n.
WEBVTT
Máme M řízených unitárních operací, každá s náklady O velkého N na druhou.
Takže celkové náklady zde
jsou O velkého N na třetí.
A konečně kvantová Fourierova transformace má náklady O velkého n na druhou.
Takže celkové náklady jsou O velkého N na třetí.
Konkrétně vidíme, že i s naším trikem modulárního umocňování náklady řízených
unitárních operací dominují.
Přesto jsou ale náklady
polynomiální v malém n.
Jsou také potřeba určité klasické
výpočty, jako výpočet modulárních umocňování a spouštění algoritmu řetězových zlomků,
ale tyto výpočty
mají také polynomiální náklady. A ve skutečnosti lze i je provést s O velkého N na třetí operacemi.
Zbývá jen jeden problém, a sice, že potřebujeme dostat do rukou jeden z těchto vlastních vektorů.
Jak to udělat?
Řešení je vlastně velmi jednoduché. Nespouštíme circuit
na vlastním vektoru.
Jednoduše ho spustíme na stavu jedna, tedy binárním
kódování čísla jedna, o kterém přemýšlíme
jako o prvku ZN.
Proveďme tedy tuto
záměnu v diagramu.
Důvod, proč to funguje, je tato rovnice právě zde.
Stav cat jedna je ve skutečnosti rovnoměrnou superpozicí R vlastních vektorů, o kterých
jsme mluvili.
A to není okamžitě zřejmé, ale pokud součet vypočítáš,
měl bys dostat cat jedna.
A pokud circuit spustíme na tomto stavu, výstup, který dostaneme,
bude přesně stejný, jako kdybychom náhodně zvolili J
a postup spustili na
vlastním vektoru psi J.
Opět, to není zřejmé, ale analýza ukazuje, že to je pravda.
A konečně, to je vše. Máme efektivní kvantový
algoritmus pro hledání řádu.
Zbývá ještě jedna velmi krátká část
lekce, která se týká vztahu mezi faktorizací celých čísel
a hledáním řádu.
Zmínil jsem, že pokud dokážeme efektivně vyřešit problém hledání řádu, pak dokážeme také efektivně faktorizovat
celá čísla.
A chci velmi stručně nastínit hlavní myšlenku, jak to funguje.
Je to zcela klasické. Tato část vlastně nemá nic
společného s kvantovými počítači.
Zde je metoda pro nalezení
netriviálního faktoru daného kladného celého čísla N.
A mimochodem, tato metoda funguje pouze tehdy, kdy N je liché číslo, které není
prvočíslem umocněným na celou mocninu.
Tyto dva případy, kdy N
je sudé nebo mocnina prvočísla, lze zvládnout samostatně.
Pro oba tyto případy existují efektivní klasické metody jak pro detekci, tak pro
jejich zpracování.
Tato metoda je pravděpodobnostní. Může selhat, ale pravděpodobnost selhání bude nejvýše jedna polovina,
a jednoduše ji můžeme
spustit vícekrát nezávisle na sobě, aby se pravděpodobnost
chyby exponenciálně rychle snižovala.
Nejprve zvolíme A mezi
dvěma a N mínus jedna náhodně a rovnoměrně.
Poté vypočítáme GCD A a N.
A pokud GCD
je větší než jedna, máme neuvěřitelné štěstí.
GCD bude faktorem N a stačí ho vypsat a zastavit se.
Jinak algoritmus pokračuje a nyní víme, že A je v ZN hvězdička.
A nyní vypočítáme řád A, k čemuž potřebujeme kvantový počítač.
Nebo možná máme jiný
způsob, jak řád vypočítat. Algoritmu nezáleží na tom, odkud pochází, ale jediný způsob, jak to dokážeme efektivně udělat,
je s kvantovým počítačem.
Pokud je řád R sudý, vypočítáme GCD
A na mocninu R děleno dvěma mínus jedna s N.
A pokud toto GCD je větší než jedna, opět máme faktor N, takže ho vypíšeme a zastavíme se.
Jinak algoritmus selhal. V takovém případě
se můžeme vrátit na začátek a zvolit jiné A
a doufat v lepší
výsledek příště.
A to je vše. A mimochodem, jakmile
nalezeme faktor N, můžeme rekurzivně pokračovat s tímto faktorem
a dělit jím, dokud nemáme prvočíselný rozklad N.
Tak proč by to mělo fungovat?
No, existují dva hlavní body. Prvním je, že protože A na mocninu R je kongruentní jedné modulo N,
máme, že N dělí A
na mocninu R mínus jedna.
Tato dvě tvrzení
jsou ve skutečnosti ekvivalentní. To je definice mod N, kterou najdeš v knihách z teorie čísel.
Za druhé, pokud je R sudé, pak tato rovnice, kterou
máme zde, platí.
To je dobře známý vzorec
pro rozdíl čtverců.
Rovnice vlastně platí pro všechna R, ale potřebujeme, aby R děleno dvěma bylo celé číslo ve čtvrtém kroku.
WEBVTT
A tedy pokud dáme obě skutečnosti dohromady, vidíme, že každý prvočíselný faktor N musí dělit jeden ze dvou
výrazů v závorkách,
protože to je jediný způsob,
jak může N dělit součin.
Nyní by se mohlo stát, že každý
jednotlivý prvočíselný faktor N dělí první
výraz v závorkách, ale ne druhý, ale pro naše náhodné A
to není příliš pravděpodobné. A tedy když vypočítáme
GCD ve čtvrtém kroku, pravděpodobně dostaneme součin
některých prvočíselných
faktorů N, ale ne všech.
Pečlivá analýza
vyžaduje určitou teorii čísel, ale jde o poměrně základní teorii čísel.
Takže pokud tě teorie čísel zajímá a rád by ses dozvěděl více, zkus tuto analýzu propracovat.
Propracovávat takové věci je vynikající způsob, jak se více naučit, ale to nechám na tobě.
A to je konec lekce. V této lekci jsme se věnovali
problému odhadu fáze, tomu, jak ho efektivně vyřešit
na kvantovém počítači,
a tomu, jak aplikovat řešení k získání polynomiálně
nákladného kvantového algoritmu pro faktorizaci celých čísel.
Doufám, že se přidáš k příští lekci, která je o Groverově
kvantovém vyhledávacím algoritmu.
Na shledanou příště.